coming up on 5 26 on your wednesday
morning yeah we've been talking about
that big squeeze on the 95 515 between
the spaghetti mill and eastern it's
about to get realer thousands of you
have gotten to know all too well the
brake light parade during both the
morning and afternoon commute but brace
yourself for more than just the
restriction of two lanes in each
direction gonna be ramp closures some
overnight one lane only restrictions
next week but the big deal starts sunday
night with the complete closure of
eastern under the freeway now indot
contractors had originally planned to
reopen the bridge on the 10th but that
closure has been extended until the 13th
so the bridge over eastern is going to
be replaced in phases this closure is so
the southbound 95 part of that bridge
can be demolished that's what the two
lanes of traffic have been all about
reshaping the center of the freeway so
the north and southbound lanes can also
be shifted back and forth to accommodate
whatever work may be going on yeah we
mentioned the closure of eastern a
couple of days ago and the detours up to
bonanza or down to stuart and as
important as i want to think our stories
are we could mention this closure all
day every day until sunday and still
come sunday night they're going to be
people saying nobody told me
check out the ndot website
i515project.com for detailed information
we got that link along with all of our
driving you crazy stories on our website
eightnewsnow.com click traffic then
driving you crazy buckle up drive
carefully please put down that phone if
there is something driving you crazy
email me traffic 8 8newsnow.com